à paroles
collègue thierry cogic pour le groupe
sia listes écologistes et républicains
merci monsieur merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre de
l'économie mais chers collègues alors
que les prix de l'énergie font l'objet
d'une hausse très conséquente vous avez
choisi en pleine campagne présidentielle
et au nom de la défense du pouvoir
d'achat de faire disons le franchement
les poches d'edf
tout le monde l'aura compris la seule
réponse que vous êtes en mesure
d'apporter face à la flambée du prix de
l'énergie relève au mieux de
l'improvisation au pire du cynisme
électoral vous fait peser sur edf
l'entière soutenabilité financière des
mesures gouvernementales de campagne
après avoir tardivement compris que
votre chèque énergie 200 euros n'avait
que peu d'effet face à la montée des
prix vous êtes aventuré sur d'autres
mesures votre décision pourrait coûter 8
milliards d'euros à edf alors que
l'urgence serait de financer le
renouvellement et l'entretien du parc
productif
force est de constater que le marché
d'énergie en france est devenue le
royaume de la financiarisation le parc
de production électrique n'a jamais
réellement été
agrandi et développement des énergies
renouvelables stack de toujours sur les
quarante fournisseurs
plus de 35 sont des fournisseurs
virtuels qui ne produisent pas un
kilowatt mais ce pécule à partir d
approvisionnement garanti par edf
le tout en empochant la différence que
l'on retrouve pour ces sociétés
domiciliées dans des paradis fiscaux
monsieur le ministre quand allez-vous
mettre en place les mesures nécessaires
afin d'arrêter de subventionner une
concurrence factice au mépris de
l'intérêt général et qui ne contribue
qu'à l'enrichissement privé on vous
répondra par an les publics de
l'économie des finances dollar lorsque
monsieur le maire
monsieur le sénateur quand est ce que
nous allons prendre avec le premier
ministre avec le présent la république
les mesures nécessaires
c'est simple maintenant gouverner c'est
choisir et nous notre choix il a été
fait c'est protéger les français contre
l'augmentation massive des prix de
l'électricité et protéger nos
entreprises contre une augmentation 1
supportable de leurs coûts de production
contrairement à ce que vous dites que
sur le sénateur les premiers à avoir
payé c'est pas le dfc l'état car
renoncer à 8 milliards d'euros de la
taxe intérieure sa combine sommation
finale d'électricité pour aider les
consommateurs et leur permettre de
supporter l'augmentation des prix
d'électricité ensuite nous avons demandé
à edf effectivement d'être mises à
contribution je rappelle que edf quand
les prix sont très bas et quand les
revenus ne sont pas suffisants peut
compter sur le soutien de l'état et un
compter sur le soutien de l'état qui
depuis 2015 lui apporter 10 milliards
d'euros dès de la capitalisation de
renoncement dividendes pour l'aider à se
financer il me paraît juste il me paraît
normal qu'une entreprise publique comme
edf participe au soutien des français
des ménages et des entreprises quand les
prix de l'électricité flambent c'est
bien ma conception des services publics
et c'est bien la conception d'une grande
entreprise publique comme edf nous avons
donc décidé d'augmenter le volume des
tarifs de l'électricité vendue à prix
réduit la répercussion sera intégrale et
les fournisseurs ne s'en remettront pas
plein les poches puisque nous avons
demandé à la commission de régulation de
l'électricité d'ici le mois de juin le
faire la transparence totale sur la
répercussion intégrale de la baisse des
prix de l'électricité sur le
consommateur final c'est à dire sur les
entreprises en particulier les grandes
entreprises industrielles qui avaient
besoin de ce soutien ce qui vous
surprend en fait que ce sénateur c'est
que pour une fois vous avez des
responsables politiques qui tiennent
leurs promesses le premier ministre
avait promis que les prix de
l'électricité ne remonterait pas de plus
de 4% pour les consommateurs français ce
sera le cas promesse tenue ça nous
change de la politique du passé
monsieur cozic
monsieur le ministre votre réponse ne me
font un me convainquent pas je vous
parle de problèmes systémiques et
structurant pour edf vous m'apportez une
réponse conjoncturelle le marché de
l'énergie est devenu en france un
gigantesque far-west financier qui ne
sert que ses intérêts où est l'intérêt
public dans tout ça cette spéculation
est une lame de fond qui grève le
pouvoir d'achat de nos concitoyens et
place des f dans une situation intenable
pour les années à venir avec cette
opération vous détruisez notre fleuron
industriel
comme le veut l'adage lorsque l'on veut
tuer son chien on dit qu'il a la rage
avec cette mesure monsieur le ministre
vous venez dans rage et edf et c'est
bien regrettable